alzi la mano chi di voi è disposto a
mettere di avere delle brutte abitudini
sono le abitudini di cui non è contento
ma che non vi vedo a ok bene fantastico
avevo paura ad arrivare davanti una
platea di santi e invece no 77 normale
fantastico vediamo se vi conosco un po
meglio cioè chi di voi se è scritto in
palestra degli ultimi tempi e non c'è
mai andato di continuo quindi non si è
abituato andare in palestra fantastici
vi adoro
chi di voi al successo modo ha fallito
l'elmetto e serietà vi adoro anche voi
siete in fantastici
chi di voi fuma e approvato tipo 20
volte a smettere di fumare fallendo
miseramente rovinandosi la vita pensando
che non smetterà mai di meno grazie al
cielo bravissimi e adesso cominciamo le
cose può più e antipatiche
chi di voi ha mai provato a cambiare
abitudini in termini di spesa guadagni
di denaro e così via
fallendo di nuovo miseramente
meravigliosi chi di voi se invece è
abituato a vivere una vita dove la
propria relazione amorosa o presunta
tale non funziona e non ha il coraggio
di cambiare la situazione di per sé
lasciare proprio maturo ma tema gettare
le basi per un cambiamento in termini
positivi
chi di voi avete paura e soprattutto
questa cosa qua
chi di voi è disposto a mettere a se
stesso di non avere spesso il coraggio
di affrontare l'ignoto e affrontare
diciamo le sfide che un cambiamento di
abitudini comporta essere spaventato
quindi dall'ignoto dall'inserto dalla
paura di non riuscire vi ritrovate in
queste situazioni
bene se questo il caso sappiate che è
perfettamente normale perché dentro di
noi quando un abitudine si consolida
alcuni meccanismi di tipo cerebrale
passano dalla nostra coscienza
diciamo intellettiva alle nostre abilità
comici
insomma e switch a no a parti del
cervello che hanno un funzionamento
automatico
cosa vuol dire automatico vuol dire che
la sostanza non siamo più noi a decidere
cosa sta facendo
ma qualcos'altro dentro di noi nella
fattispecie i gangli della base
dovete sapere che un abitudine è così
difficile da scardinare non perché sia
bello perpetuare comportamenti idioti ma
perché una volta che un abitudine è
diciamo piantata al nostro cervello
questa non viene più gestita dalla
nostra coscienza dal nostro intelletto
la regia di alcuni automatismi che ci
portano a completare una sequenza di
azioni in modo istintivo avendo una
punizione interiore che difficilissimo
alla contro grave quindi falliamo
miseramente perché questa pulsione è più
forte della nostra attualità a livello
neuro scientifiche questo tipo di
meccanismi si sono studiati negli ultimi
dieci anni in veramente moltitudine di
maniere un modo se volete piuttosto
curioso è legato a esperimenti sui topi
dove si dimostra che se voi prendete un
topo e lo mettete in una gabbia chiuso
da uno spazio e una volta aperta la
saracinesca con un forte rumore il click
il topo comincia lentamente a esplorare
lo spazio
finché a un certo punto torre al
cioccolato il cioccolato nella
ricompensa questa ricompensa consoliderà
nel cervello del topo che è piacevole
arrivare a fare un certo tipo di
comportamento
il fatto che cos'è è che la prima volta
che il tuo pof questo tipo di cosa ci
mette un bel po di tempo ci mette tanto
sforzo
dopo 7 8 volte che fate questo tipo di
trials il comportamento del topo diventa
automatico e va molto veloce verso la
ricompensa
quindi il topo ha sviluppato un
abitudine se è abituato a sentire il
clic della saracinesca e ad adottare una
sequenza di azioni che gli permettono di
raggiungere la ricompensa
quindi il discorso è un po questo il
clic attiva in automatico il
comportamento necessario a ottenere una
certa ricompensa ok quindi quando parte
click non è più la nazionalità o
l'intelletto mettiamo così del topo a
guida il comportamento ma qualcos'altro
questo qualcos'altro sono proprio i
gangli della base è una sede a te
strutture del sistema lean dico che noi
non controlliamo a livello conscio
guardate è veramente incredibile notare
come nei primi round di questo tipo di
esperimenti sui topi si osserva che
l'attività cerebrale dei topi è molto
forte e intensa nella corteccia una
volta che dopo è stato condizionato e si
è abituato a un certo tipo di
comportamento basta il clic per far sì
che l'attività nella corteccia cali in
modo molto forte
passi come automatismo ai gangli della
base e guardate un po soltanto alla fine
pa ma riprende quindi che succede ci
siamo abituati a spendere i nostri soldi
un certo modo puramente c'è un innesco
che fa sì che abbiamo una sequenza
automatica di azioni piantate in testa
ci siamo abituati a fumare o hanno un
andare in palestra oa mangiare in modo
sbagliato o qualsiasi altra abitudine
vuol dire nel tempo abbiamo messo
insieme tutta una sequenza di cose che
ci permettono di stare tranquilli o
comunque di raggiungere le nostre
ricompense
il vero problema è che in tantissimi
casi ci si rende conto di quanto le
nostre abitudini sono dannose quando
quasi ormai troppo tardi
conosco personalmente persone che hanno
deciso di smettere di fumare solo quando
un amico è passato a miglior vita
conosco persone che hanno deciso di
mettersi a fare ginnastica in modo
continuo perché il proprio medico ha
fatto loro intuire che molto
probabilmente la qualità della loro vita
sarebbe inevitabilmente stata
compromessa perché dobbiamo aspettare
che sia troppo tardi per poi andremo
alla nostra vita pensateci un po chi di
voi vorrebbe arrivare in un momento dove
è quasi troppo tardi prima di accorgersi
che certe cose che sono utili per la
propria resistenza vengono presidiate di
come la propria esistenza anche a
livello di aziende
seguiamo aziende per reimpostare delle
abitudini nel gestire alcuni tipi di
meccanismi e non c'è nessuna differenza
si fa una fatica bestia
l'importante è sapere dove mettere le
mani
quindi il discorso di fondo quale vi va
di pensare ad applicare dei principi
scientifici che vi possano aiutare a
smontare le abitudini che vi danno
fastidio
cioè se vi rendete conto che non sia una
cosa nella vostra vita non vi piace vi
piacerebbe avere una guida per riuscire
dire ok fermi tutti se vogliono
modificare la mia vita devo fare xy z
bene il tentativo che cercherò di fare
proprio questo
se ti prodotti alzi la mano chi non è
pronto bene st tutti quanti provati
bravi ok prima cosa da fare inondarsi di
dopamina come sognando e non sto
scherzando prendendosi il tempo di
sognare i risultati del nostro
cambiamento di un comportamento cambiare
abitudini è difficile e capiterà
sicuramente un momento di difficoltà
sicuro come l'oro che si può fare in
quei momenti rimanere focalizzati sul
perché stiamo cercando di cambiare
visualizzando come può essere la nostra
vita
nel momento in cui eliminiamo per sempre
siete tipi abitudini dico per sempre che
se in realtà una volta che l'abitudine
dentro di noi è piantata basta un solo
click
un solo re impulso per far sì che
comportamento ripeta
ed è per questo che così difficile ad
esempio eliminare una dipendenza
patologica come dal gioco sostanze
stupefacenti quindi dobbiamo capire
perché se la stanza dicano di fi e qual
è l'obiettivo che stiamo cercando di
raggiungere senza questa visualizzazione
della nostra vita sarà quasi impossibile
riuscire dei nostri obiettivi secondo
elemento gradualità si riesce nel
cambiare una propria abitudine solo a
piccoli passi soprattutto piccoli passi
e cioè il miglior modo per fallire e
pensare che da un giorno all'altro
cambieremo tutto la nostra vita
quindi che cosa si può fare ad esempio
se il mio obiettivo è quello di iniziare
una nuova vita in termini di prendermi
cura di me e diventare
atletico mangiare meglio prendermi cura
meglio di un'assoluta eccetera
non devi pensare di buttare nel cestino
tutto quello che ho fatto fino a ieri ma
introdurre una piccola nuova abitudine
che potrebbe essere come il fatto di
fare una passeggiata di 5 minuti tutti i
giorni per un certo periodo
ok vedrete che la soddisfazione degli
riuscire ad autoimporsi una piccola
modifica nella proprio stile di vita
sarà sufficiente a darvi sicurezza nel
adottare altre modifiche quindi la
passeggiata invece che cinque minuti
potrebbe diventare i 15 di un'ora e
potrebbe essere poi collegate a un
cambio di alimentazione e così via
quindi il primo meccanismo da siamo
cercare di evitare è quello di pensare
che dalla sera alla mattina
se cambia tutto roma non sei così tanto
giorno vero quindi bisogna starci un
pochettino attenti
terza cosa bisogna allenare il carattere
cioè gli impulsi che si portano a
perpetuare un abitudine sono forti e se
noi non abbiamo il controllo di noi
stessi
è molto probabile che cederemo di
continuo le tentazioni niente paura
capita a tutti di cedere a qualche
tentazione
il problema è che quando la tentazione
prende sempre sopravvento e quindi a un
certo punto bisogna chiedersi davanti
allo specchio
chi comanda e chi vogliamo che comandi
cioè voi volete che qualcuno dentro di
voi che non siete voi a livello conscio
prenda per voi delle decisioni utili a
l'immediato ma non utili al vostro
futuro e alla vostra salute e il vostro
benessere e la vostra felicità anche
perché by the way per le statistiche
circa la felicità delle persone ci
dicono che circa il 30 per cento della
popolazione vive di continue una vita
insoddisfacente perché non ha avuto
magari il coraggio di prendersi cura di
se stesso di modificare le proprie
abitudini rendendola un po meglio la
propria vita ok
com'è che si fa allenare il carattere
meglio se si parte fin da bambini ma in
ogni caso perché prendersi cura di sé e
imparare ad autoimporsi delle cose
facendo capire a qualcun'altro dentro di
noi chicca comanda quindi mettersi
davanti allo specchio di s
chi è che comanda qua sono io che
comando quindi anche se sento degli
impulsi che vengono dal sistema limbico
devo frenate devo imparare a dire no
adesso no faccio altro ok meglio da
piccoli perché perché dimostrato che chi
ad esempio sviluppo delle capacità
musicali o è appassionato di sport
diventa fantasticamente capace in
termini di carattere di autonominarsi e
io guardate solo la prova esistente di
quanto questo se è vero niente di quello
che ho fatto nella mia vita compreso il
laurearmi compreso l'aver fondato
un'azienda di neuromarketing che oggi
cast al secolo fa piuttosto bene e
lavora con soddisfazione lo devo
veramente in modo profondo al mio
maestro di tromba e al fatto di essermi
auto torturato a sufficienza per
riuscire a diventare un modesto
trombettista è un training che poi
traslate su una valanga di altre cose
quindi se avete l'occasione
iscrivetevi anche voi musicale o fate
scrivere i vostri figli
altro spunto cambiare i trigger abbiamo
capito che è il click il problema bene
se noi viviamo in ambiente dove gli
inneschi ai comportamenti non ci sono
più la probabilità che noi aiutiamo
nuove abitudini aumenta e quindi che
succede se io sono abituato fu mai dopo
il caffè cosa faccio posso eliminare il
caffè sapendo che la voglia di fumare la
sigaretta si sa di più ossa e riuscirò a
dominare la meglio
ok quinto spunto fatti sostenere cioè in
tantissimi casi si riesce davvero a
modificare i propri comportamenti
quando la nostra volontà di cambiare
qualcosa diventa pubblica e ci facciamo
aiutare da qualcun altro quindi invece
utilizza i social network per fare
soltanto un attività di stalking
possiamo anche utilizzati per prendere
posizione in modo pubblico e dire ok
guardate che io della mia vita voglio
cambiare questa cosa ed è un ottimo modo
per avere il proprio successo in questo
tipo di meccanismo penultimo elemento
che voglio raccontarvi riguardo al fatto
di crederci questo perché perché tutti
quanti noi abbiamo detto il nostro
cervello un reticolo di aree che si
chiama
reticolare activating system che fa da
filtro alle informazioni che arrivano al
nostro intelletto conscio e quindi che
succede succede che quello che noi
percepiamo della realtà non sono tutte
le informazioni disponibili ma
soprattutto alcune e quello che questo
reticolo va a fare è favorire quelle
informazioni che ci danno ragione e che
confermano idee che già abbiamo quindi
cosa accade ma crede che se io comincio
un percorso di cambiamento pensando che
non ce la posso fare e quindi avendo
anche soltanto un piccolo dubbio di non
riuscirci il cervello andrà a farmi
passare di continuo alla coscienza tutta
la serie di formazioni che dicono sai
cosa non ce la farei mai
quindi che succede se non si abbraccia
davvero l'idea di voler cambiare per
qualche motivo un'abitudine sarà quasi
impossibile riuscire e se non ci
crediamo noi
indovinate un po c'è che si crederà per
noi nessuno l'ultimo spunto che vi do
se volete è forse più importante perché
perché in tantissimi casi si tratta di
cominciare e la difficoltà legata al
cominciare è che se ci viene voglia di
cambiare con gli aspetti la nostra vita
poi dopo qualche secondo cominciamo a
aver paura di fallire
aveva paura di essere imbarazzati di
dire agli altri le cose aver paura di
non farcela è tutta una serie di cose
che sono legate alla nostra attualità
quelle cose lì che dobbiamo far tacere
e un modo a mio avviso molto
interessante per riuscire a fare questa
cosa qui è la cosiddetta tecnica di 5
secondi di mary robbins
non so se ne avete mai visto parlare di
noi nessuno
fantastico questa tecnica è molto
semplice consiste nel fare un
semplicissimo conto alla rovescia
partendo da 5 e una volta arrivati a 0
iniziare a fare qualcosa che si collega
al modificare una questo per evitare che
poi razionalizziamo ci facciamo troppe
paure ci facciamo troppo
i pensieri sul fatto che non ce la
potremo fare e così via
quella roba di la mettiamo a tacere e
cominciamo punto quindi sapete che
facciamo per evitare che questo
intervento non vi sia davvero utile
quello che vi chiedo di fare è la
seguente cosa
tutti in piedi su dai allora pensate e
pensateci sul serio parlo con tecnica mi
sergio paolo conte gomiti coming to ok
tutti quanti voi uno per uno come se
vivessi in una stanza dove fossimo io e
uno di voi pensate ad una cosa della
vostra vita che vorreste cambiare e
pensate sul serio
non faccio il motivatore di lavoro la
testa però ho bisogno di questo tipo di
cosa per far sì che questo meccanismo
funzioni pensate a una cosa che davvero
davvero volete togliere dalla vostra
esistenza
pensateci guardatela visualizzate e
adesso andiamo applicare una cosa di
quelle che abbiamo visto e cioè il
prendere un impegno pubblico quello che
vi chiedo di fare adesso tira fuori i
telefoni e segnare in agenda che domani
mattina alle 10 vi prendete l'impegno di
scrivere un post su facebook o di
scrivere a 5 vostri cari amici che avete
iniziato un percorso dove volete
riuscire a modificare una certa cosa
ok e chiedete aiuto se non a un certo
punto ve la sentite di andare avanti
ok non deve essere una cosa stroppa la
micron è una cosa troppo vomitevole da
essere imbarazzante potesse una cosa
seria
siete pronti avete il telefono in mano
pronti 5 4 3 2 1 e iniziato a scrivere
scrivetelo sul serio e non fate come
tutte quelle volte che avete detto voi
stessi ma no ma poi mi imbarazza ma che
cavolo ne so
sarebbe bello ma alla fine poi non lo
faccio che cazzo ne so ok se volete
fallire fallite tranquillamente ma
cercate per quello che potete di tenere
conto di una cosa oggi la giornata
finisce a mezzanotte giusto da qui in
avanti sarà possibile rivivere la
giornata di oggi no
domani o dopodomani no quindi anche se
la nostra testa il tempo scorre in modo
circolare in realtà ogni giorno passa e
quando è passato non torna più abbiamo
un occasione
ottima di rendere la nostra vita
indimenticabile felice e sana
augurabilmente cerchiamo di non buttarla
via
per questo vi saluto
[Applauso]